sweetie pie
ine-san limo feed the power
what then
assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullah wa
better care to brothers and sisters and
dear friends welcome to reality 11 on
this episode we're going to be talking
about the broken promise the promise
that was given to a certain sister from
a brother regarding marriage and he had
all the vital signs there to build the
trust of the sister well that didn't go
to plan and the sister was left
traumatized we're going to go straight
into that interview but before we do
obviously as you guys know pure
matrimony sponsored our shows and it's
the most halal website to find your
partner and all the halal means are
there for you and the options on the
site for you to tailor a halal approach
and inshallah get married now brothers
and sisters we're going to go straight
into the interview and hear the sisters
story and we're going to be straight
back and talk to you guys inshallah of
where the sister went wrong what could
she have done and what she should have
not have done and inshallah this will
help us and help you inshallah
to benefit from it and do not fall for
the same trap we're going to be right
back in Charlotte
Socialists are so going straight into it
how did you meet this individual first
how how do you know he was a close
cousin of one of my very close friends
so I was perhaps close friends house
regularly and obviously he'd be there
too so initially our conversation
started from that point and we just
became friends okay and how would you do
that and thirteen thirteen eighteen but
he was he was fourteen state local this
is the first time you met its first time
ever we've known uh yeah that he was
just friendship that's right yes what
point did he approach you with maybe
feelings not until I was 18 and that's
initially when I was approached by his
close family and friends because it was
too nervous and you know he had the
decency to not approach me himself so he
had sent people that were close to him
to speak to me and you know just kind of
know what my intention was
at that stage so he and how old was you
then and I was 18 he was 19 okay with 18
that he was 19 and he basically at that
age he wanted to take things further
that's right so he got his family
involved that's right and someone from
his family members I told you that's
right an order reaction and obviously
cuz I was really young I was nervous we
small place a lot of people to our cars
I've always been scared of people trying
to frame me until you know about what
you're doing don't do so I was nervous I
was innocent I didn't want to pursue it
at the time and so I just carried on
talking to him like you know nothing's
been said but obviously along the way
because I knew of its tenth intentions
and because I was going through a lot of
the time and he was my system of support
someone along those lines I fell from
and we pursued a relationship okay so
the fact that he's approaching obviously
young age you know male and females were
a bit naive had that aged him taking the
right approach or getting the family
involved I'm sure he gave you a bit of
security of okay he must be serious
cuz I've known him so long I knew who's
a decent character and I had never heard
about that about him you know the way he
spoke to me the way he's played to his
family members the way he spoke to
people he was known as you
a respected guy he he was just a good
man I'm obviously like said he was
protective of me he wouldn't you know it
was almost like my shield who look after
me he would you know he was just a good
person I could never doubt that he would
have you know the wrong intentions
towards me and towards anyone and so you
did it so basically you did say that you
went through some kind of depression try
to clean yeah I did that this was just
this was well this is not the age of
birth about 15 16
it's just initially when I went inside I
was friends with him probably at that
point we weren't in touch every single
day and I went through a phase my suffer
from depression and took some stupid
steps hard to commit suicide so it was
it was pretty intense and I then got a
job working in a local area where he
happened to work he became aware of my
situations my health and he gave 100%
ensure that I was okay tip mentor
counselors you know medical roots
everything just initially I was a write
checking up for me all the time and so I
suppose he was my sense of kind of he
had that sense of care that's my moral
support emotional support mental support
he was there if anything had the best
friend so all that stuff is going
through he was there for you it was
there he he's he was there through thick
and thin he was already standing there
and he continued to stand there despite
and support I got from my family
he didn't think oh I'll back out now
she's got a family he was just there as
the best friend throughout everything
that I was going through okay so I'm
sure like having that kind of support
from him and was your feelings like at
that moment was you because because
obviously he's at that moment of time
and this is after his family approaches
you in who's 18 right this was just if
both my depression was there what I was
getting to know him okay him 9 what I
was going through his family had
approached me after that's what the
approach of I'm sure you obviously when
somebody cares away so much you have
experience towards him and then his
family approaching you maybe you know me
too you know seemed more legitimate so
okay so family approached you and what
happened next and so like I said I
respect him like nothing happened didn't
even consider what I've been approached
I just wanted to keep his friends at the
time because I was so young but like I
said I think because I got the back of
my head I was aware of his intentions
and the fact that he was you know it was
decent he was good who respected me you
know he he cared and he showed it that a
lot of 3s actions so somewhere along
those lines I fell from it as well I'm
supposed cuz there wasn't really a flaw
in him and I won when I thought about my
future I thought this is the person I
want to be with and obviously most girls
aren't the type of girls that King kind
of you know pluck up the courage and get
to know somebody French though because
he was a friend for so long I was so
comfortable and so confident that this
was it you know it was him you close
with his family members extremely close
muscles my best friend's mainly siblings
were best friends so that was kind of
like a reference way like it's like you
had that trust yeah yeah okay so what
happened as long as you said a family
member of his Apostoli that's right and
a member of his family passed away and
obviously he was this before this is his
family member passed rate just before
they approached me to pursue a
relationship also just before and he
completely broke down and obviously
there was like short paper we didn't
talk because he needed time to himself
but I remember when his family member
passed away it was that point now I've
always had that regret in my heart why
didn't I take the step to meet this
individual so you know for a very long
time that regret the thing that over me
and I remember when I decided to pursue
this relationship I spoke about my
feelings but you know I'm sorry I wasn't
I didn't meet this individual I'm sorry
I didn't you know make the effort and he
took that regret regret away by taking
me to this family members grave and
introducing me so he took that work
right away in a matter of seconds for me
and for someone to do that it just
seemed so sincere so genuine and like I
said I wasn't I didn't feel like I was
blinded in any way I just felt like this
was real he was genuine you know his
intentions are genuine and this is what
I wanted so where does it come to the
point where did you speak about marriage
we did yes okay what What did he say to
you I did he said you were gonna get
married wait for me let me find a job
here's that tears up he obviously made
his intentions clear that he wanted to
marry me I heard that's really startling
members as well you know his parents
know he wants to get married you know
this isn't his intention
what are your family like how'd you want
to this obviously I'm a girl I would be
very scared at the young age of you know
19 say to my family you know I have
somebody that I want to marry especially
when I've got much older siblings no I
was scared so I said I did say to him
look not just yeah not just sure not
just yet please not just you don't we
just find a way to do this um
so which is carried on you know as it
was and but all along it was never a
case where it was boy you being like
your friend she has never nobody could
ever say that I was his girlfriend when
he was my boyfriend he had that much
respect me all he had ever said to me
was one would get married you know he
would see families walking past his
workplace you know when can we have
firmly you know he had that vision of
the future I'm not what we could do at
the moment but he was just Cynthia
everything seemed so genuine so he
wanted to get married on you because of
you was holding about I was holding it
back I won't deny everything cuz I was
very young I said like we will do this
but let me find a way of doing it I
didn't say we're not gonna do it now I
think I need to find somebody in the
family that I could talk to you so I did
eventually I she spoke to an extended
family member who I was very close to
and I spoke about and she said okay fine
you know um speech him on the speech he
died a speech his system I I was scared
you know I mean it's natural to have
that feeling you know because in this
you know day in age society will
instantly say well you know look at her
age and you know she was doing this as
she was doing that it was the fear of it
that was holding me back but in the
long-term and my intention was that this
is the person that I wanted to marry
okay so did when did they go down to
that for example did he have a turn
where it was he wants to get married
you're saying wait did have a turn where
he was like let's get married and he was
like what would happen obviously then he
Asami understood he and said he did come
to agree that he was relatively young
and obviously he wanted to be a bit more
stable kind of build up you know I kind
of did a bit more for himself and so
then he decided to focus on his career
I decided to face in my career and we
just started getting on that way nothing
had changed between us we still spoke
breaking OD everything was not fool
everything was just an intact until one
day I just noticed we start to speak
less than this so I approached him said
is something bothering you you know miss
nothing happened I never did I doubt I
had done something
never did I say what have I done because
I knew I'd given him you know the best
amount I mean so good to him I'd
respected him up you know I was always
there for me had financial issues you
know I provided he had family issues I
was there you know any problems he had I
had the solution I've got my way just to
make sure he was okay so I couldn't pass
me think well understand what could be
so wrong that he's slightly pulling away
or slowly distancing so this is phase
where you like you're giving it you 100%
now and I've given it a hundred percent
from the beginning I've given it much
more now because I knew that he told me
he has x y&z problems so I gave
everything I had just ensure he was okay
and when I managed to resolve his
problems I still found that something
wasn't right but he was still not
talking as much or he you know tried to
put me off of cause we've tried not to
text but could just not be around he
they know but we don't talk at all like
I mean I mean back then back then yet
here was storm concept with me but very
rarely like he would but we were still
in touch we still had the intention of
marriage but I found that he wouldn't
want to have a conversation with me
anymore so every time I would ring
you know I'm busy speech later if i text
wouldn't text back or even if he saw me
passing by hi you okay will create
almost like he didn't know me and I
found that almost like Collier cows
teaching aides know what my off-time to
be become so-called like was it like
over appeared or five months under
severe initially he's his image side to
change he started going germ he started
looking after his you know just physical
appearance and everything can he he went
into a lot of a bigger office where he
had obviously more attention for mobile
okay so life's changing and he's may be
getting more time that's right he he
started to get that attention
obviously it may be from a blog that he
became a bit more vain you can almost
say and so that point I realized when he
tried started to change in himself for
himself was when he started to change
towards me also so he became because I
didn't think that was a reason I didn't
think that you know just because he's
trying to do so you really had problems
all what these just excuses just to
avoid I think at the point when it
everything was happening I thought they
his problems mother his reasons because
I don't want to believe or accept that
the person I've known for this long has
now changed especially when you've had
the intention of taking it all the way
to marriage you know when you haven't
found a flaw in someone as long as being
a certain way for so long you don't want
to accept that they can change in a
matter of six seven months but if I was
to look at it today and now I was
honestly blinded because for what was
his excuse is became almost like my pain
like I did everything to make it better
for him you know but for him it was just
excuses really just to put me off and
you know maybe go for something better
for him in his world you know something
that he maybe he wanted more of
something else you know whatever he's
like whatever you wanted he obviously
decided I wasn't good enough or you know
whatever whatever it was but I never had
it from him as harsh as it sounds I was
approached by a friend of his and said
just leave him alone he doesn't want it
anymore and that was it whose friends
yes leave him alone you know he doesn't
want it anymore just leave sort of thing
I never heard it from him that's all and
then the person that was initiative a
DaCosta so his siblings that's me oh
he's happy without you no reason us no
nothing along the lines of really sorry
this is happening do you know and are
you okay well we need to sit down and
talk to you it was just as harsh as
leave him alone doesn't want it anymore
and he's happy without you till this day
I don't want to believe it I didn't I
didn't believe her even I had heard it
from his immediate family I still texted
and called him like nothing happened
because I had molded my whole life from
my whole future around this one person
like I remember at tender age of twenty
twenty-one you know when
the talks of him wanted to marry me was
still in the air I remember looking and
saying this is what I want to wear on my
wedding or this is what I wanted you
know I had yeah I've started putting
things together you know obviously what
girls at the end of the day we've got
this thing you know at the end of the
day it's LOM doesn't say that you know
you can't fall in love
of course you can but obviously there's
a right way of doing it and you know if
I intend she was always there so I was
looking at this is what I want to wear
because at the age of you know 20 ish I
was intending to pursue it to her family
you know I thought it was a bit more
sensible so I did I put everything
together my plans venues I discussed it
with him you know he was cooperative so
he knew I was building my whole life and
my whole future around him he was fully
aware they were they were it wasn't only
my dreams it was me so now I changed out
you know like the fact that he wanted to
get married to you and you said wait do
you think they'll play the fact of him
basically thinking you know okay I'm
trying this table is not working so they
just well you know what forget that I'm
just thinking what do you think that my
afraid about I would agree to some
extent that maybe it did however I think
even after he and even after I told him
why I couldn't yeah you know at that
point he understood and if he any point
felt now I can't wait for you who should
have left but he didn't he he was there
for a further two years if his
intentions could change or he didn't
respect that you know that my decisions
that he might have to wait longer he
should have left it's wrong for him said
pursue that for a further two years it
wasn't right because not only did he
shatter my dreams but he destroyed it
was his soul just ring because you
change being from the same area I felt
like I couldn't be my home was at home
anymore I didn't want to be at home but
there's memories memories everywhere I
didn't want to be well with I used to
lock myself away in my room and you know
like I used to stay awake the whole
night and the only way I used to fall
asleep it suffice to cry and cry and cry
my eyes he says fell up you know I'm a
heavy snake and that would put me to
sleep you know it was hard you know
the Mobile's about depression I didn't
and Hum Dil I didn't but I'm I know that
I changed as a person in a sense that I
didn't feel like I have a big family so
in a house full of people I was still
alone but I was the their fault that was
my fault because I was taking out the
grief that he had given me on my family
but I didn't realize I was doing that
it's just when you have that pain you've
rebelled I rebelled in a way where
instead of taking it out on the person
who has done this to me I took it out on
my family and that was wrong
with my dad or my mom or my sister would
come and ask me and I was wrong
since I'm really sorry for putting you
through this but have you heard of him
ever since that for example because you
said that you heard stories from people
that he's done this to true other
individuals yeah okay so I don't want to
believe it because I've 90% on cell but
never now he's character obviously when
everything had happened I'd left and I
just need at that time so kind if you
know rebuild myself and I used to kind
of run away from home and you know not
want to look back because just it feel
like things are different on whom
reminded me why I was being different
and then being in the area that I was
just it was just memory really because
you've known someone for so long and
because you've molded your whole life
you know in and around them everything
will remind you of them whether it's a
place you've gone to eat or whether it's
a road that you've driven by or whether
it's person that you've spoken to that
cement you everything will remind you of
that person so I struggled a lot I
decided to leave my job and I decided to
get a job in a completely different area
far away from home just so that I
wouldn't have to face Holmes and Luthor
again I don't want to face everything so
I decided to pick up blocks that a job
completely out the way compared the area
I I remember the time that he obviously
won't pursue emotion he did tell me to
stop talking did this this and this mess
and I did it so at the point I he'd left
I actually had no one around me not a
friend no one at all and that was for
the reason that he wasn't happy that
these people being in my life say so you
change your own life so you left your
friends everything I I yeah I listen to
everything he'd wanted me to friends
career everything and so at the point
that he left because I had left people
for him I found myself being alone but
like I said even with a house full of
people I was still alone because I
wasn't able to talk to them and every
time they would ask me what's wrong well
you know my sister world has faced
always said to me say miserable stop
ruining the family you say moody yes I
grumpy but inside I wanted to scream out
to her like this is happening to me this
is wrong with me but they on the outside
go away or get lost that would hurt me
because I'm taking my grief out on my
sister in a disrespectful way that would
hurt me no it's true he reminds me of a
brother that I know he would when he
came to Islam like you know he went
through like this kind of difficulty and
he spoke to her and the Bravo saying
like you know when you make your
happiness your life your everything your
whole world an individual when the
individual leaves your happiness
everything in your life sleep yes it's a
reminder to us but I want to come back
to the point before we kind of finish
off is now have you ever heard of him
like after after after that like has he
ever made I am yeah has he change for
the better
have you change for the worse I had
obviously I'd like that I made and I
didn't look back and I just didn't look
back I I know that a lot of people were
talking about me because it made us so
aware that I was almost labeled of his
and I knew that yeah because that was
one of his things he's like can you
start telling people so people know that
you know can you please tell people so
that we can pursue this and then the
more people know that may be exactly
that so he wanted me to kind of make it
aware that that there is somebody in the
picture and I did it for his sake that
you know he's so serious that's why he
wants people to know so one of the
reasons I couldn't be in and around the
arrows because I could hear people
saying and what happened most wasn't
some being said to me I remember walking
past a group of girls and said oh that's
her
you know he dumped her cuz she wasn't
worth him so it made me think what did I
do less or where did I go wrong you know
what did I not give you know I always
question myself and because I'd asked
myself so many questions I made myself
self believe that I was the bad one you
know I I believe with myself because of
all the questions I was asked myself
more people were saying it's it's hard
that you know home isn't home anymore
your home should be payment for me it
wasn't but I did hear when I came back
coming soon I decided to cut myself
together you know and you know really
trying tolerance whatever bit of
strength I had and I decided to come
back
I'm just get on with life despite what
people said I remember being approached
by two girls I had never seen before and
asked me if I was okay I automatically
assumed that maybe they've heard things
I said I'm flying they said don't worry
he's done that to us as well so he
easily so two individuals approached you
and they know you obviously because they
knew he was gonna marry you and he's
done the same to your other sisters okay
and how was your reaction when you heard
it I was numb did you feel like wow or
was you like hum Duloc was in a way like
for example you you must have thought
you know what maybe that's how he really
was it's better that this happened what
was going for yet they were very honest
any despite knowing all the negatives
that he has done I can't really find it
in my heart to hate him because I think
the good times for me overwrite the bad
times and in some way as a person I feel
like I'm a better person now than what I
was back then like my siblings are my
best friends and my parents are my best
friend had I have not gone through that
experience I would have never
appreciated who my real people are and
like I said wherever I go whoever go it
must have still would be with me if I
have a problem I don't hold it in I will
speak it out to my sister because I've
learned from that experience or
straighten it has it's definitely shaped
me you know but one thing is that I will
always struggle with is marriage what's
meant to be a girl's dream is is now my
biggest fear I cannot imagine having a
union with a male I can't picture it
I have no excitement no happiness
towards there you know when people get
married I used to used to always be the
one that wanted to go to weddings and
now when as a family wedding I avoid it
so that's one thing that I still
struggle with to this day because of
trust you know because of what I've gone
through because of fake promises words
you know though his actions were shown
and his words were thrown it was still
it was it wasn't real you know if I
still fell for it because for me you
know you but at the time it just seems a
sincere Salaam alaikum guys welcome back
you've heard the sisters story and I'm
sure you was touched and traumatized as
much as I was of what I heard myself in
person also we're going to have another
who's meant to do the interview with us
but unfortunately due to personal
reasons he backed out but this was the
same brother who went through the same
exact problem with what their sister
went through but with the woman that he
was with and he not only left him but
when and married somebody else so
brothers and sisters we need to
acknowledge this happens to both
brothers and sisters and we both need to
learn from the following things which
I'm about to tell you what you need to
understand it's very very clear in order
for us and not for for these sins and
these mistakes and even though if we do
we can learn from them but as you know
Islam is there not as a cure but as a
prevention so what do we do we have to
cut the problem from the reach now what
does most people do they act with their
logic how they think okay I found
somebody he likes me you've got that he
shows me affectionate you've got that
he's with me through thick and thin
you've got that he's involved this
family we can never go wrong but the
main fundamental that your whole lives
be based upon which is Islam and Allah
sport Allah the fact that you don't get
a lie involved that's where the problem
comes now robbers and sisters you need
to understand you cannot work and base
your life around logic and thing
yeah that's there this is there that is
there Oh everything's gonna be fine if
you do not involve Allah in your worldly
affairs how do you expect any better cut
to come with it then you can't be
surprised and say oh why did it go wrong
of course it will go wrong if you do not
bring the main the one who's created you
the one who knows what's good and bad
for you and if you disobey that and say
let me go with logic he likes me family
over here well this is what's gonna
happen so what do we do we avoid that
cut it from the roots now let's move on
now that we've acknowledged that we need
to involve Allah so Allah with our
affairs we need to take that step how
now when you're involving all of your
worldly affairs and matters you don't do
it the way you want it by saying okay I
said miss Miller and I go and commit
zina don't fool yourself you involve
Allah how he wants to be involved and
what is the right step to take you do
not get involved in a relationship
outside my car number one number two you
have to get in the car done once you've
done this then it has done there's
butter in your marriage and you pursue
it now if you say but hold on a second I
know somebody that got married did it
the right way the guy went and end up
cheating hold on a second if that is the
case for arguments
if that is the case then you've got no
sin upon you my sister or brother if you
did stuff the right way and they went
off and cheated on you or did whatever
you've got no sin upon you because you
did the right thing gonna be a judge
when your hands are clean but if it's
both of you and you're in the act and
you don't do it you're both are sinners
we can't believe it and I don't mean
this in a harsh way but you see even
Allah's mercy
he's oft-forgiving most-merciful now
brothers and sisters even if you fell
for this sinner
look how merciful you Lord is come back
to me he's the one that loves to forgive
sins he's oft-forgiving most-merciful
come back if your sincere repentance not
only would your sins be forgiven but all
those bad things that you didn't
sincerely repented for will be turned
into good deeds what else do you want my
dear brothers and sisters Allah your
Lord is oft-forgiving most-merciful
acknowledge that in your head and
brothers and sisters not only is your
Lord forgiven but he's also generous the
Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu was seldom
said in a hadith that if you need
something for sake of Allah Allah so
Allah will replace that with something
much more better if you say you know
what enough is enough I want to do stuff
the right way you leave that girl or you
leave that guy for the sake of our luck
watch how unless want I'll oppose barek
in your life and replaces that not only
with good deeds but a better individual
he will come and do the car the right
way for you now this is what we need to
understand me myself I'm a living proof
of this well llahi I'm telling you leave
something for the sake of Allah and
watch how it's going to be replaced with
something better to conclude if you fix
your relationship with Oliphant Allah he
will fix your affairs and your
relationships with the people we need to
acknowledge this there's no running away
from it there's laws that are lost want
on a sit in place if I drop this glasses
it's gonna fall there is laws that
govern the planet that we live in and
Alice Montana has different laws that if
you disobey you will fall for it even
though you fall for these mistakes
it's a rama from him because those
mistakes will bring you closer to him
what I was gonna say brothers and
sisters that's about it from me if
you've liked the video share it with
your friends it show you guys a benefit
may Allah's mercy or blessings be upon
you or all praises and glory belong to
Allah for the works that we do
thank you very much have a brilliant day
[Music]
[Music]